en el vídeo anterior comenzamos con el
concepto de variable aleatoria
vimos dos tipos de variables aleatorias
las discretas
discreta que toman un número finito de
valores finitos significa que no podemos
tener un número infinito de valores para
una variable discreta y tenemos
variables aleatorias continuas continua
las cuales puedan tomar un número
infinito de valores el ejemplo que les
mostré para las continuas era algo así
aunque voy a cambiar un poco las cosas
en lugar de usar x mayúscula voy a usar
ye mayúscula normalmente se usa la x
mayúscula pero yo voy a estar poniendo
las y se usan mayúsculas por lo general
para las variables aleatorias que es la
cantidad exacta de lluvia
que caerá mañana últimamente ha llovido
mucho en donde vivo por eso tengo en
mente la lluvia
y aunque no conozco la función de
distribución de probabilidad de esta
variable voy a dibujar una para que la
podamos interpretar y ver cómo podemos
pensar acerca de las variables
aleatorias continuas permítanme dibujar
esta función de distribución de
probabilidad que llamamos función de
densidad de probabilidad
el eje x es la cantidad de lluvia que
caerá 0 centímetros 1 centímetro 2
centímetros 3 centímetros y 4
centímetros y en el eje ya tenemos
cierta altura y se me ocurre que el
máximo aquí mide 0.5 la forma de pensar
en esto es si vemos esto y yo les
preguntara cuál es la probabilidad de
que yo que es nuestra variable aleatoria
sea exactamente igual a 2 centímetros
con base en lo que tenemos en la función
de distribución de probabilidad para
esta variable aleatoria aquí tengo dos
centímetros subimos y vemos que tiene el
valor de 0.5 así que tendrá una
probabilidad de 0.5 yo les digo que no
es de 0.5 y antes de que veamos cómo
interpretarlo visualmente pensemos
lógicamente en esto
es la probabilidad de que mañana caigan
exactamente dos centímetros de lluvia
12.01 centímetros de lluvia ni tampoco
1.99 centímetros de lluvia ni 1.999
nueve centímetros de lluvia y tampoco
2.000 01 centímetros de lluvia sino
exactamente 2 centímetros de lluvia
ninguna molécula extra de agua ni una
molécula menos de agua alejada de
nuestra marca de 2 centímetros quizás no
sea tan obvio para ustedes cuando
escuchan que cayeron 2 centímetros de
agua ayer pero tienen que imaginarse
exactamente dos centímetros muchas veces
las personas cuando ven 2.01 dicen ah
pues son dos pero este 2.01 no cuenta
para nuestro ejemplo tampoco nos sirve
el 1.99 tiene que ser exactamente dos es
más no contamos siquiera con las
herramientas necesarias para medir con
exactitud dos centímetros ni siquiera
una regla puede medir con exactitud
a 2 centímetros ya que por como
fabricamos las cosas siempre habrá un
átomo extra por aquí o por allá la forma
en la que podemos pensar acerca de las
variables aleatorias continuas es decir
cuál es la probabilidad de que ye sea
casi 2 si dijéramos que la probabilidad
del valor absoluto de yemen los dos sea
menor que 0.1
para que no se confundan esto significa
cuál es la probabilidad de que ye sea
mayor que 1.9
y menor que 2.1
estos dos enunciados son equivalentes
esto comienza a tener más sentido ya que
tenemos un intervalo aquí
estamos hablando de toda esta área
y el área es algo clave ya que para
calcular la probabilidad de que esto
ocurra tenemos que encontrar el área
bajo esta curva desde este punto a este
punto y para que ellos ustedes que ya
comenzaron a estudiar cálculo esto es
igual a la integral definida de esta
función de densidad de probabilidad
desde este punto a este otro punto
digamos que esta gráfica esta línea es f
x
la probabilidad de que esto pasará será
igual a la integral para aquellos de
ustedes que están estudiando cálculo la
integral que va de 1.9 hasta 2.1 df x
con respecto a x
este es el eje x algo importante que
tenemos que darnos cuenta es que una
variable aleatoria puede tomar cualquier
valor dentro de un intervalo si queremos
la probabilidad de exactamente 1.9 999
es de 0 pues cuál es el área bajo la
curva en este punto o en esta línea es
más cuál es el área de una línea si
dibujaremos una línea el área sería base
por altura la altura podemos calcularla
pero cuánto mide la base cuál es su
ancho por definición una línea no tiene
ancho y por lo tanto no tiene área esto
nos da la noción intuitiva de que la
probabilidad de un valor exacto va a ser
igual a cero por otro lado si nos
preguntáramos cuál es la probabilidad de
acercarnos a dos entonces sí podemos
definir un área cuál es la probabilidad
de que caigan entre uno y tres
centímetros de lluvia mañana
bueno pues vemos que tenemos una
probabilidad más grande es toda esta
área también nos podemos preguntar cuál
es la probabilidad de tener menos de 0.1
centímetros de lluvia que está aquí y
podemos calcular esta área o podríamos
preguntarnos cuál es la probabilidad de
tener más de 4 centímetros de lluvia
mañana comenzamos aquí y calculamos el
área de aquí hasta el infinito si es que
la función se extiende hasta el infinito
aunque esperamos que no sea un número
infinito pues de ser así esta
probabilidad no tendría ningún sentido
pero imaginemos que la integral nos da
un 10% de probabilidad de que caigan más
de 4 centímetros de lluvia mañana todo
esto debería hacerles ver que el área
total debajo de la curva o que todos los
eventos posibles combinados a la vez no
pueden ser mayores que el 100 por ciento
toda el área bajo la curva tiene que ser
igual a 1 la integral de fx
a infinito al menos para esta función
que dibuje con respecto a x debe ser
igual a 1 para aquellos de ustedes que
aún no están familiarizados con cálculo
la integral es el área bajo la curva y
si quieren aprender más pues pueden ver
la lista de vídeos de cálculo en khan
academy lo mismo aplica para las
variables aleatorias discretas en las
que la suma de todas las probabilidades
también debe ser igual a 1 veamos un
ejemplo por monedas voy a dibujarlo aquí
hay dos probabilidades que deben ser
igual a 1
aquí está uno y aquí está cero
uno es si cae la moneda en águila
y 0 si cae la moneda en sol
aquí en el dibujo a más de 0.5 aunque no
siempre tiene que ser así si águila es
0.6 entonces la probabilidad de sol será
de 0.4 la suma de ambas siempre tiene
que ser uno no se puede tener una
probabilidad 60% de águilas y 60% de
soles pues acabaríamos con una
probabilidad de 120 por ciento de que
ocurriera cualquiera de esas
posibilidades lo cual no tiene sentido
así pues es importante recordar que una
función de distribución de probabilidad
en este caso de una variable aleatoria
tendrá que ser igual a 1.5 punto 5 y en
este caso de la variable aleatoria
continua la función de densidad de
probabilidad también tiene que ser igual
a 1 y hasta aquí llegamos en este vídeo
en el próximo veremos el concepto de
valor esperado